patrick corbin fp comes into the night
with a 6.09 era his last start just
three innings at miami gave up two home
runs six runs in total
ground ball
should be a tailor-made 6-4-3 and it is
nicely turned there by garcia and
sanchez
right pitch selection just didn't get it
where he wanted to
harper on the ground
there's sanchez
shallow and right and a lead off single
does not
come around to haunt patrick corbin
scoreless top of the first nationals
will go to work against matt moore they
need a big game out of more tonight
without a doubt you see the numbers he's
allowed 14 home runs
averaging three and two thirds in his
last three starts zimmerman hitting 308
against left-handers 190 against
righties and the 3-1 pitch
a towering pop-up
right side of the infield yeah big time
and segora makes the catch and the
inning is over couple walks few extra
pitches than matt moore would like
another good slider bonifacio swings
through it ruiz will throw down out
number two here in the second
[Applause]
this one drilled to center thomas over
pretty smooth first two winnings for
patrick corbin here tonight
six batters faced
two clean innings
and a strength recalled on the outside
corner
corbin down looking
it's matt moore's first punch out
they've gotten away with one there so
now two out with two on for lane thomas
here's the set and the 2-2 to thomas
swinging a line drive to the gap in left
center field this is trouble it's down
on one hop taken by the center fielder
bonifacio in the scores garcia stopping
at third sanchez in its second with a
double and a run bat and in his lane
thomas
swinging to miss he got it with 93.
now the side is retired
well that's a good fastball and it kind
of goes to your point
against lane thomas the nationals do get
one will go to the third
neither did the third
ruiz is going to throw down in behind
the runner
bierland gets back in there but barely
they're gonna say matt moore went around
dan iasonia had to check with third base
umpire scott berry
he had not initially ruled matt moore
out on strikes
swinging a miss
slider below the zone and patrick corbin
gets out of a third inning jab
is supposed to be standing the right
spot every single time good point
josh bell
on a line into the right field corner
bryce harper will play it off the wall
josh bell hustling into second on a head
first dive
one out double for a guy who increases
his extra base hit total now an rbi
opportunity for ryan zimmerman
this one down the left field line josh
bell will cruise home
and ryan zimmerman
rbi double here in the bottom half of
the third it's two nothing nationals
teams do have a mutual off day on
thursday garcia to the pull side
and fair
one hops into the nationals bullpen
three doubles for the nationals here in
the third inning
have played it two runs thus far
bouncer back to the mound knocked down
by moore
1-3 on the put out assad is retired two
more runs score though three doubles in
the inning
and the nationals leave a couple as the
rain starts to fall lightly these last
two starts against the fills
the nationals have lost
harper buns toward third it's a fair
ball over the bag
and he's aboard love it
last two starts for corbett against the
fills eight runs six home runs
and a high fly ball to deep left field
bells going back it is gone
a two-run home run from mccutcheon
number 22 for catch
and the phillies are within one it's a
3-2 ball game do a catch
even walked back in the first and struck
out in the second
left center and deep
almost to the same exact spot as last
night
home runs in back-to-back ball games for
carter kibum now six on the season
all of them coming in the month of
august
and joe is heading out
belly falters coming in so we'll have a
pitching change here in the fourth
inning
it's that one sharply segura kind of the
same play as bell
and he throws out ruiz
the inning is over but some damage two
run home run by carter kibu
that one's in there
patrick corbin
strikeout number four
ground ball softly toward third corbin
has it nobody's covering third what a
break for the fills or run scores it's a
5-3 game
little chexing swing excuse me ground
ball the second adrian sanchez makes the
play
and patrick corbin limits the damage in
the top half of the fifth frustrating
inning for him i'm sure
but allows just one run
rashfield marchand will be the batter
nick maton again moves to the on deck
circle he will bat for the pitcher
marshawn hits it out toward left center
field bell's on the run it is gone
it just slips over the wall into the
phillies bullpen raphael marchand
has tied this ball game up at five
we got a new fuego and davey martinez is
out of the nationals nugget
so now andres machado will take over in
a 5-5 game
swinging a line drive back through the
middle of base hit one runner's in
rounding third heading for home as
galvez he'll score going to second bases
harper he's out at second base it's a
two-run single and the phillies take the
lead seven to five
mccutcheon bounces one fair down the
left-field line
that's gonna get another run home and
the phillies lead it eight to five it's
an rvi double
for andrew mccutchen
and the o2 pitch
and a line drive bases it to right field
mccutcheon the third and he's being
waved home the throw
it dies on a bounce rbi single for
o'double herrera
9-5 phillies
and a line drive out toward left center
field he's got another hit and it's
going to go to the wall
and burling can run so he's on his way
to second he is there standing
lead off double here in the ninth inning
and here is brad
that one's down the left field line
doesn't have enough bells going back
it's gone the opposite way for brad
miller
just over the nationals flower bed
a two-run home run for miller off the
bench
and the phillies lead it 11-5.
[Applause]
no one gets away and here comes segora
he'll score it's 12-5
[Applause]
ground ball over the mound galvez has it
throws to first in time in the ball game
is over
and the phillies have come from behind
and they've won it by a final score of
12 to six
you